-Good evening, I'm Seth Meyers
and this is "Late Night."
How is it everybody doing
tonight?
That sounds good.
Let's get to the news.
President Biden traveled to
Camp David this weekend
on an extended August vacation.
Luckily he managed to
get out of there right before
the Taliban took it over.
The Taliban yesterday entered
the city of Kabul and took
control of Afghanistan's
presidential palace.
Most Americans watched in horror
while some Americans
watched for tips.
The Taliban has officially
declared victory in Afghanistan
nearly 20 years
after the U.S. invasion.
Though it was just rude
to use the banner.
In a new interview, Secretary
of State Tony Blinken discussed
the Taliban's rapid takeover
of Afghanistan,
but not before trying
every other possible topic.
"So, who's watching
'White Lotus?'"
President Biden has announced
plans to send
more than 5,000 troops
to Afghanistan
as U.S. forces continue their
withdrawal from the country.
Though I'm not sure
it makes sense to send people
to a country to get people
out of that country.
You know what it's like.
You ever try to leave a bar
with your friends,
and you're all outside
and one guy is still inside,
talking to somebody.
So your friend goes in
to get that person
and then they don't come out.
And before you know it, you're
there for another 20 years.
It's like that.
Former President Trump released
a statement on Friday
amid the deteriorating situation
in Afghanistan,
and, yeah, he's enjoying this.
Supreme Court Justice
Stephen Breyer
turned 83 years old yesterday.
Seven of the other justices
wished him a happy birthday
with Clarence Thomas
writing the dissent.
New Jersey Governor Phil Murphy
is facing criticism
for taking a vacation to Italy
amidst a spike
in coronavirus cases.
He knows he can get that food
in Jersey, right?
Their state flag is
sausage and peppers.
[ Laughter ]
Today was director
James Cameron's 67th birthday.
And he celebrated the same way
he does every year,
by not releasing "Avatar 2."
[ Laughter ]
The fast-food chain Wendy's
announced last week
that it will open 700 so-called
ghost kitchens
that only prepare food
for delivery orders,
and it will not include
a dining room for customers.
And in case you've never seen
a Wendy's dining room,
here's what it looks like.
[ Laughter ]
And finally,
authorities in New York
are looking to question a couple
after an MTA train operator
allegedly let his girlfriend
drive the D train last week
through multiple subway stops,
and she was so bad at it
that none of the passengers
noticed.
[ Laughter ]
And that was the monologue,
everybody.